[Musique]
je soupçonne un acte criminel époux
n'exclut aucun suspect
[Musique]
je suis
/
ciao
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la situation dans le pacifique
et bien pire on le dit
pearl harbor et le plus gros échec
des services de renseignement bonjour
[Musique]
et japonais prépare quelque chose de
plus
elle est la cible 1
on pense que c'est mieux
washington n'est pas d'accord
washington se trompent pas
on n'est donné qu'à temps
[Musique]
mais on va tromper
qu'on vaut mieux que ça
[Musique]
pour vous souviendrez de ces instants
toute votre vie
voilà votre i
il n'ya pas d'oiseau
le météorologue est pas venu vous
accueillir
[Musique]
où se trouve le météorologue un matin il
est parti et je n'ai jamais revu
j'apprécie votre sollicitude mais je ne
repartirai pas tout de suite
[Musique]
l'envié de rester sur le bateau le
météorologue qui étaient là vous l'avez
laissé dehors comme moi
j'appelle ça un meurtre non tirées pas
ici je suis libre maître de ma destinée
à mieux la lumière humaine ou divine des
démons de l'atlantide
dieu et conquérir sur la nature de
l'être humain et vous voulez les
conquérir peu les exterminer
à bayeux
il n'y a qu'une chose à comprendre nous
sommes des envahisseurs ce qui fait de
nous des ennemis
[Musique]
un homme demande à te voir il t'a trouvé
grâce à un contact à interpol un chinois
avec une mallette et un parapluie
votre nom sean l'eau vous cherchez quoi
votre aide vous êtes les meilleurs sur
le marché
l'antre du diable
dis moi la vérité c'est quoi cet endroit
à sa soeur terroristes trafiquants héros
de l'humanité
weir et tu peux m'aider sur ce coup là
tu auras besoin de moi
moi j'ai mes seules ses personnels à
langer
point d'entrée liaison drumm établi que
40 prisonniers dans le secteur ouest
il dirige une prison secrète danger
maximale restez sur vos gardes
bonne chance on a de la visite en piste
tout le monde
hebron témoin soir le fils de mon ex
associé on n'échappe pas son passé
breslin on va se retrouver
autrement
tu me connais je bosse mieux seul
souviendront de moi
j'adore ce bruit
quel dommage que tu sois pas là
ab
tu aurais pu aider mon père maintenant
je vais te briser
[Musique]
ma vengeance
vous mettez d'écraser la gueule
j'en ai assez de prison
la floride se prépare à l'arrivée d'un
ouragan de catégorie stock partait au
plus vite dans moins d'une heure on sera
totalement sous l'eau
opus sera jamais les bras
growl la floride se prépare à l'arrivée
d'un ouragan de catégorie 5 parties au
plus vite
je vais passer par le conduit
d'évacuation ni trop dangereux au puits
sera jamais
ahmed toi espèce d'enfants
il ne me reste plus beaucoup de temps à
vivre
amman il y une chose dans ce monde que
tu dois savoir tutoie savoir faire une
bonne fée vous trouvez pas ça étonnant
outrance ils viennent jamais précisément
de nos vacances avec qui tu vas te des
plus les la bouche que tu veux dire
sa dernière volonté jenny ça c'est pas
depuis la nuit des temps
citant la bible
[Applaudissements]
on pourrait rentrer regarder la ville et
ses 7 buts
je crois que tu ferais bien sa rentrée
aujourd'hui je vous rencontre le coeur
triste l'euro terwingen nous a quittés
vendredi
[Musique]
je m'appelle luc jamie
je crois pas au coup de foudre milhas ce
genre de choses mais je suis persuadé
qu'on peut rencontrer quelqu'un il
savoir instantanément
cette personne contrat pour nous
[Musique]
je voulais qu'on passe du temps ensemble
je voudrais bien lieu elle existe génial
bas mot vieux mas delta j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été lavé tous mes
péchés citoyens découvrent pour nous
deux on des palettes passe quelque chose
je voulais que ça arrive
c'est ta grand-mère qui te manipule
depuis l'au delà c'est à grand mère
vient de mourir que ça donne le droit de
te comporter comme une [ __ ] à l'église
toute cette histoire ce qui concerne ses
mails étaient complètement dingue
on a été triste jean boulet mais quand
on en tirera le bilan comprendra que
toutes les erreurs en effet seront
probablement de très bonnes serrures je
n'avais plus rien à perdre je ressentais
la présence de dossiers à m'écouter
il m'encourageait peut aller chez ml si
tu veux non pourquoi elle est privée de
sortie et ben moi maintenant je
comprends pourquoi tu tenais temps aller
à lille
on
[Musique]
chef c'est une très grosse affaire un
caïd de la mafia qui s'étaient adressés
[Musique]
mais le tipi et ça c'est un tueur en
série
c'est quand même la honte un gangster
comme toi qui se fait défoncer ok tu
cherches quoi je veux celui qui t'a
attaquer
[Musique]
je te filmer homme et je couvre toutes
les frais
le mec appartient au premier qu'il
coince marché conclu le gangster et le
flic s'associent pour choper la salsa au
[ __ ] c'est du lourd
sans à la hauteur
[Musique]
pour finir trois types ont risqué leur
vie à ce petit jeu
[Musique]
il
le guen johnson
la sécession aux ja
low cost
non
[Musique]
on vient
[Applaudissements]
la x type
à thé coca diouf du boîtier
m6 tout soit
déchets
washington 3 points
[Musique]